اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه 26 عسكريا في
معارك قطاع غزه وذلك خلال الساعات
ال4 الماضيه وقد تحدث عن اصابه
2797 ضابطا وجنديا منذ بدايه الحرب
1283 منهم اصيبوا منذ بدء الهجوم
البري وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان 300 و8
ضابطا وجنديا ما زالوا يتلقون العلاج وان
جروح
35 منهم خطيره ومن جانبها افادت صحيفه
يدعوت احرنوت الاسرائيليه ان اعدادا كبيره
من الجنود الاسرائيليين يعودون من غزه وهم
يعانون من اعراض نفسيه
وانفعال ومعنا الان من غلاف غزه مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام اذا اوضاع الجنود وعدد
الاصابات بلا شك له تاثير كبير على الداخل
الاسرائيلي الى جانب ما يجري من متابعات
ميدانيه بعنا في صوره اخر المواقف
الاسرائيليه لو سمحت الياس
تفضل بالفعل ليلى والقصف المدفعي والغارات
الجويه تكاد لا تتوقف على الاقل في
الساعات القليله ال الماضيه قبل قليل قبل
لحظات فقط كان هنالك استهداف لمنطقه ما في
شرق جباليا هذا اثار الدخان المتصاعد من
المنطقه المستهدفه كانت هذه غاره جويه على
موقعين في المناطق الشرقيه ل جباليا وكذلك
هو الحال منذ ساعات الصباح هذه المناطق
التي تستهدف بالغارات الجويه وكذلك القصف
المدفعي وان كان متقطعا لكنه مركز على
مناطق بعينها في تلك المنطقه ايضا المناطق
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه كانت تعرضت ايضا
لغارات جويه مكثفه هذا اليوم بالاضافه الى
قصف مدفعي ما زلنا نرى تصاعد الدخان
الاسود من اكثر من موقع حقيقه في المناطق
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه حيث نحول الان عدسه
الكاميرا باتجاه هذه المناطق التي استهدفت
ايضا في الدقائق الاخيره من خلال غارات
جويه وقصف مدفعي الواضح بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يركز على هذه المناطق الجنوبيه
لمدينه غزه منذ يومين على الاقل معظم
الغارات الجويه تتركز في تلك ال المناطق
وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول ان يقيم
حزاما ناريا يمنع من خلاله اي تحركات
للفلسطينيين بين المناطق الوسطى والمناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه وبالتالي هذه المنطقه
المستهدفه في جنوب مدينه غزه هي منطقه
العبور المفترضه اذا ما كان يحاول
الفلسطينيون التوجه من المناطق الجنوبيه
بالعوده الى المناطق الشماليه الى ما تبقى
من منازلهم في تلك المناطق وبالتالي يبدو
ان كثافه النيران التي تشكلها المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه والغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه
على تلك المنطقه هدفها منع اي تحركات
للفلسطينيين بين المناطق الوسطى والشماليه
لقطاع غزه فيما يواصل الجيش الاسرائيلي حث
الفلسطينيين على مغادره منازلهم كما فعل
في الايام الماضيه في الاحياء الغربيه
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه حيث طلب من
الفلسطينيين الباقين هناك المغادره الى
المناطق التي يقول ويدعي بانها امنه في
المناطق الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه قبل ايه اقل
من ساعه كانت هنالك اشتباكات ايضا ليلى
كان بالامكان رصدها في وسط مدينه غزه
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه وكانت قريبه
جدا حتى من مبنى مقر الجزيره في مدينه غزه
اشكرك على هذه المعلومات الياس كرام من
غلاف غزه